hello and welcome to this video playing
whiplash okie dokie okay green felt I
could also play kings inion ig3 anyway
okay so i'm going with a c5 based
approach yeah councils castles I said
hmm ok takes with the Queen anyway okay
Knight takes is the more about more
common way of playing this it's a bit
surprising that he takes with the with
the Queen oh wow so h6 would threaten g5
now probably not bad yes to move the
Queen again now what what is happening
here what a game what kind of stuff is
that ok so um let's see how would you do
that
we should each six probably I mean okay
I'm a piss-up but still you want to make
sure that it doesn't get some some some
weird planes and we had coming to play
ok I have maybe can take a 95 but well
it's a piece come on my idea is that
well other Queen doesn't really have any
square so we probably will trade queens
195 we can play ah that's actually
interesting move 95 hmm he goes Knight
be five yeah I thought 95 would have
been would have been annoying okay but i
can trade now go to the eighth well this
doesn't attack much right i mean if i go
d6 here you would have to move the night
or capture so he captured now the more
c5 could become a problem yeah
definitely
I can play d5 though so probably I can
develop this actively the hard time now
to not trade Bishop f3 there's um Bishop
g4 okay so I sorry this is I didn't see
that move I forgot about that okay so
maybe it's prevent c5
tip it silly an that didn't see Bishop
age one okay it's not a big problem it's
still just a piece but I just didn't
have it on my radio ok so now okay
that's all the good idea let's let's
push it back and push this back
Jim doesn't have a good square it goes
to d4 I am not so clear Oh didn't expect
that move okay if I take with the rook
that's 94 I can take with a pawn down
this is a pretty clean solution I think
jhalak and now i'm attacking his pawns
by quite quickly this is a taxi for now
almost if I take these got c5 but I have
looking for also coming so what do I
take I can also take well but this is
also a good move attacking this I ba6 I
have Luke a8 so yeah that is ok I will
take a six and all the points before i
no then then it checks on the seventh so
92 I had 92 okay what the end game
apiece up is still rather comfortable
come rather comfortable um okay
yeah what's easiest maybe this one to
open up the rooks often look on the
sixth-ranked okay let's push some points
check check this one how do I get it the
most reliable way well it's probably
okay aged six days 94 yeah this also
will check window porn check
check check yeah I can do this first you
need to give him anything check white
resign yeah was weird right he gave me
that piece straight straight from the
opening yeah okay 24 already is slightly
and I'm coming ninety-fourth normal here
and ya know black has a choice um twin
twin to c7 as an interesting idea like
this and there are 93 is what they
normally do but yeah okay Quincy 7 this
is an interesting idea that was
fashionable or has become fashionable in
recent years was funny to see because I
had found that not found and not like
invented it but I want to have to
rephrase that it's a line that I had
seen them a couple of years ago in a
database and F had thought this is
rather interesting the idea is that this
this is a funny idea yeah 90 x this is a
mistake all ready because here Ruby aid
will win we win the peace and then it
become fashionable okay anyway and we
had this and yeah queen d 4 is strange
because of the 96 you have no good
square until after age 60 he has to go
queen efforts the only move and it's not
clear what all those Queen moves have
accomplished yeah after this is g 5 i'm
winning just winning yeah you can argue
probably I didn't this is probably not
good what I did by the way this is ok
but after this this the move Queen h5 i
think is probably not so great as he has
95
this is a little bit uncomfortable takes
I have to check yeah I cannot Jack make
do that yeah but this and now this is a
little bit more annoying than the game I
mean okay it's a piece for to pawn so
ultimately it should win but it's it's a
bit awkward yeah I cannot do this I
would like to play that move but this is
starting to look really ugly so I have
to take and after pawn takes 95 night f5
this is um Mia yeah I mean clearly
better for black but it's not not so
easy to win he's got some activity and I
think that wasn't necessary yeah this
however should be pretty okay I didn't
see that one coming but I'm preventing
c5 and as long as he doesn't get any
direct activity there is nothing to
worry about him and jen roughly yet
became rather simple to win and was a
bit surprised that he continued for so
long it's very little that that black
and yeah I can do wrong now you just
pick up all the pawns okay thanks for
watching